if we were you wouldn't be helping earth
to Ariel as the only Disney princess
with a child we're sure you'd like the
official lineup to expand to include
more members your daughter totally
deserves a spot in the franchise and
there are lots of other female
characters that have easily earned their
place alongside you and dear fellow
princesses have a chat with the execs at
Disney and put in a good word for these
ladies the more the merrier right these
10 heroines totally deserved to become
official Disney Princesses three of them
were even part of the franchise once
upon a time keep watching to the end to
discover how a popular non Disney
character could actually now qualify to
become part of the lineup
Megara my friends call me Meg at least
they would if I had any friends official
Disney Princesses first things first
let's list the 12 official Disney
Princesses they fall into three
categories there's those who were born
into royalty whether the daughter of a
king Sultan or chief that Snow White
Aurora Ariel jasmine Pocahontas Moana
Rapunzel and Merida and there are the
princesses who became royal by marriage
that's Cinderella Belle and Tiana
finally there is one lady who is
considered royal through her acts of
heroism and that's Mulan frozen was so
successful that Anna and Elsa got their
own affiliated franchise rather than
joining the princesses but what about
the other female protagonists that would
be the perfect fit to join the official
lineup let's start with Ariel's daughter
melody there's no denying that melody is
a princess after all her dad is Prince
Erik and her mom is Princess Ariel but
she doesn't officially qualify for the
lineup because she was introduced in a
sequel also the Little Mermaid to
returned to the sea wasn't at the at
Racal release however we would love to
see a new generation join the lineup hey
dizzy please make animated features
about all of the princesses daughters
vanellope von schweetz the record Ralph
Starr is the sugar rush princess so it
makes total sense that she becomes an
official Disney princess after all her
similarities with the other Disney
Princesses were overtly pointed out in
Ralph's bricks the Internet am I'm a
princess too we love seeing them all
together and Penelope could keep making
that happen just imagine a movie about
the entire princess franchise amaze
kitty-kitty is the heroin in Atlantis
the lost Empire she becomes Queen in her
movie so she's got the Royal credentials
and fans would love for her to add some
diversity to the lineup but perhaps her
age thousands of years old has stalked
Disney executives from adding her in but
age ain't nothing but a number and just
imagine the kid at costumes Tinkerbell
did you know that the mischievous fairy
from Peter Pan used to be a part of the
official lineup once upon a time but
it's thought that Tiana replaced
Tinkerbell on the line up because the
fairy had developed her own franchise we
adored the Disney Fairies franchise and
don't understand why tink can't be in
both bring her back Disney Esmeralda the
heroine from The Hunchback of Notre Dom
who's also an official Disney Princess
until 2004 it's thought as Narada was
removed because she wasn't selling as
much as the others in the franchise but
she is such a heroic character and would
bring more diversity to the lineup we're
sure cells would increase dramatically
after the live-action remake is released
to Jane Porter we've got one more
character that was once considered part
of the Disney Princess lineup only to be
taken out at a later date in 1999 soon
after the franchise started Jane from
Tarzan was listed as an official Disney
Princess
but his thought that she didn't remain
part of the gang because of fashion
reasons
apparently her dress colour scheme was
too similar to Belle's give her a new
dress Disney and let her back in Giselle
Giselle from Enchanted is different from
the rest of our entries and she's
represented in live action as well as
animation and the complications of that
like pain amy adams royalties might well
be why she wasn't added to the lineup
but the Golden Age Disney Princesses
inspired her character with her love of
sewing and talking to animals so she
would fit right into the franchise Alice
we get why the star of Alice in
Wonderland isn't a part of the official
princess lineup after all she's not
royal by birth marriage or a heroic deed
however she is referred to as a princess
in the short animation Disney Princess
sing-along
songs enchanted Tea Party she even
brings along English scones with cream
and damn mogera mogera from Hercules has
also been included in some official
Prince's products like the album
Disney's princess collection vol 2 she
was also in the animation Disney
Princess sing along songs once upon a
dream with her song I won't say I'm in
love meg would bring an interesting past
to the lineup and in Greek mythology
mogera actually was a princess so it's
not like she wouldn't fit in with the
other girls Anastasia Anastasia is the
daughter of a Tsar who is an emperor of
Russia so she takes the Royal Bach but
she couldn't be part of the official
Disney lineup because her movie was
produced by Fox Animation Studios
however 20 years after the 1997 film was
released Disney acquired 20th Century
Fox so it's no wonder there are rumors
that this heroic character will join the
Disney Princess franchise soon so that's
a wrap on the 10 characters that should
be a part of the official Disney
Princess lineup which is your favorite
let us know in the comments make sure to
subscribe to the things for more Disney
Princess videos and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll see you again soon
[Music]